keeping britain at work has proved a
challenge as omicron has surged new
figures from the office for national
statistics show three percent of the
workforce was absent because of covid at
the end of last month
now the health secretary has bowed to
pressure to cut the self-isolation
period in england from seven to five
full days from monday people can test
twice before they go
leaving isolation at the start of day
six two-thirds of positive cases are no
longer infectious by the end of day five
and we want to use the testing capacity
that we've built up
to help these people leave isolation
safely joe mills owns three salons in
soho a third of his staff have been off
in recent weeks because of kovid but
he's not sure the new isolation rules
will make that much of a difference it's
test on the fifth day and then again on
the sixth day and then come back to work
if you're clear
but
you know how what percentage of people
are testing clear on day five and six i
don't know you know so
yeah any anything that anything that
shifts
the requirement for quarantine is going
to be a bonus according to the uk health
security agency only five percent of
people are infectious after the old
self-isolation period of ten days
under the current rule of seven days and
two negative lateral flow tests the
chances of being infectious rises
slightly to six percent
with the new five-day isolation time and
negative tests on days five and the
morning of day six the chances rise
again to seven percent
some scientists are skeptical about the
economic benefit we know that many
people will continue to test positive
after five days and will continue to be
isolating um also we know that many
people don't work seven days a week so
there will be some people who will no
longer be isolating but it will be in
their days off so when you actually try
to look at the impact that it will have
on the economy it may be much less than
is being hinted at only three quarters
of people complied with the full 10 days
of self-isolation the hope of being
released after five might help it's a
calculated risk the health secretary
says boosters testing and antiviral
treatments will be crucial as britain
learns to live with a virus but
infection rates are still high hospitals
are still under enormous pressure and
there's always the chance of another
variant
in another sign that life is moving on
professor sir jonathan van tam is
leaving his role as a government medical
advisor there were no tortured metaphors
from him this time just a wish that
cavit had never happened
thomas more sky news